[Musique]
grand matin 10 degrés à hell-bourg au
programme la cima saron on va tourner
autour du piton des neiges 55 km 800
participants
mais exceptionnellement vous aurez deux
émissions pour le prix d'un on s'arrête
à silence et ensuite on enchaîne
ça va être c'est un endroit où il ya une
station taille donc
bon voilà élevé au village beaucoup pour
les plus beaux villages de mode
tout est réuni pour que ce soit une
belle fête du travail voilà je souhaite
bonne chance à tous les participants qui
profites tu le parcours béquille une
parka bonne santé qui reviennent en
bonne santé c'est tout mais que tu n'es
pas stressé parce que les paysages sont
beaux et
et que c'est cool c'est fini à oissel
progrès là que je tremblais en sortant
de la voiture et j'ai pas trouvé de
réponse à ma question
ouais c'est ça pendant la journée j'y
réfléchirai
[Musique]
quand on a un mental s'est toujours
trouvée
[Musique]
alors on va y aller moins vite c'est une
stratégie sont ici
alors dans les bois doubs et voilà on va
se promener alors ah oui c'est ça
[Musique]
paillot souvent y arrivent à l'heure
là
oh
moi
[Musique]
ah ça répète année c'est quand j'étais
encore avec force que le plaisir de
découvrir la nature
les premiers rayons du soleil sur les
plus beaux sommets à une seconde à ça
c'est cadeau l'occasion de vous parler
mais voilà ce qu'il ya derrière moi du
gîte départementale si vous voyez
régulièrement des travaux c'est qu'il ya
un grand plan de rénovation qui est en
cours pour tous les gîtes départementaux
mais tout ça pour améliorer la pratique
de la pleine nature
c'est vrai que mes choix de signaux ça
va trop top
trop tard et jolie tout moment elle va
prendre plaisir les gaffes et julien à
super atom franchement c'est pas là
j'entends c'est beau allez venez danser
péter yes
[Musique]
tout va bien ça va
ok tu fais de fléchissement parce
qu'après le pli gaza venir que lucho
sans plus meyer genou montagne ah oui ça
désaltère bien sûr et aziz ça me donne
l'info sera des nageoires où il ya qu à
la réunion il donne l'énergie à windows
7 en cas de travail c'est une terre de
cambodgiens s'étaient passionnés c'est
celle aventure syncada aventure en fait
sur le piton des neiges
mais au dessus de la ville on sillonne
la route d'ilet à cordes
l'occasion de vous parler de ces taux
qui tombe et qui ruisselle et baal est
récolté dans deux sources même 3 vous
explique ça tout de suite
[Musique]
la découverte des sources thermales sûr
si l'os date de deux siècles
1815 et depuis de nombreuses années le
département est propriétaire de ces
trois sources
il est en exploite directement une
partie au travers des soins qu'on
propose
il délègue une partie de l'exploitation
à l' usine de l'autre si la hausse
mais le département est tout à fait
engager dans la valorisation de cette
ressource naturelle
[Musique]
oui
coc
je ne sais pas
de dire au trailer vous avez la chance
d'avoir un outil un équipement qui
valorise cette ressource naturelle
n'hésitez pas pendant les cours pendant
les entraînements à venir profiter de ce
bien fait la totale
[Musique]
rutile et accorde une route
départementale entretenu par les agents
du département
c'est comme ça qu'on termine cette
émission terre de trail la deuxième
partie sur la cima ça c'est bientôt
en attendant vous vend vase un extrait
des routes et des hommes la retrouve
dans les sentiers bella ont bien sûr
bien sûr la route et 10 à ta grotte
c'est là la route départementale 242 la
première phase dont c'était la piste là
c'était vraiment c'était formidable pour
une première puisque le mariage
après il ya eu donc la deuxième phase
c'était le vêtement chaud c'est le
confortement des ouvrages
[Musique]